a very public Rao is broken out between
the wives of two high-profile
footballers Wayne Rooney's wife Killeen
has accused Jamie Vardy swype Rebecca of
leaking stories from her private
Instagram account to the Sun newspaper
the wife of the former England captain
made the accusation on Twitter
she says she devised a scheme to limit
who could see her Instagram feed to work
out who was passing on the information
well Rebecca
body responded to the claims denied
deliberately making any stories and
suggested her integrand Instagram
account may have been hacked let's get
more than this our correspondent know
Phillips is here this is a story that
will be it won't just have one page in
the tabloid newspapers tomorrow I
suggest you may have several indeed and
clean Rooney on Twitter
they're both trending home Rebecca Vardy
she's been described as a modern-day
scooby-doo for her investigative work
not at all but that there's a lot of
praise for Kelly Rooney's efforts in
sniffing out their spy who she's
accusing Rebecca
Vardi of basically you know watching her
stories on Instagram and then feeling
those stories to the tabloids
Rebecca body is of course denied those
allegations she she's released a
statement I think just a short time
after clean Muniz a very public and
private post about the allegations she's
basically said that as I said to you on
the phone and I wish you had called me
if you thought this I never spoke to
anyone about you as various journalists
who have asked me to to do so over the
years can vouch for if you thought this
was happening you could have told me and
I could have changed my passwords to see
if it stopped over the years various
people have had access to my Instagram
and just this week I found I was
following people I didn't know and I've
never followed myself I'm not being
funny but I need but not but but I don't
need the money what would I gain from
selling stories on you I liked you a lot
Killeen and I'm so upset that you've
chosen to do this especially when I'm
heavily pregnant so she's expecting her
fifth child very soon and she ends the
post of the heartbroken emoji which I
think sums up perhaps how she's feeling
about these allegations you wonder where
there's the matter rest so what if this
is it doesn't feel like this is the end
of it it feels like the start of
something quite explosive I think it's
like there's scooby Doo
I mean I'm not sure what the ending
might be in this case but I think there
will ultimately be pressure on clean we
need to perhaps release those
screenshots that she's referred to in
her statements which allegedly shows
Rebecca Vardi and viewing her stories
and those stories then ending up in a
tabloids I think one of those stories
you know and involved clean Rooneys a
house flooding and apparently that very
same story was a big splash in the Sun
newspaper the following day in and I
think it's worth pointing out that was a
fake story so I think that's why I need
Mooney it's alleged I think we need to
keep using word alleged quite a lot it's
alleged it's a fake story it appeared in
a newspaper yeah but whatever else that
feels like there's an accusation of a
serious breach of trust between two
people used to be friends that's for
sure isn't it and it makes you think
about all these other stories that we've
seen the press I mean could Dave pad
potentially been on to about celebrities
may you know those who good grief know
come in here with your I have principles
yeah I do know how the story ends though
Colin she would have got away for it if
it wasn't for gets good money for this
Sky News is trying to contact both
Coleen Rooney and Rebecca Marty's
official agents we are waiting for an
official response from both parties our
thanks to know